okay so let's start by drawing a clap
and get on to the wrong person sent so
here's my client all right now as we
have seen the formula for this metaphor
we're going to need some diagonals on
here ok so again get your ruler out and
as a bonus if you've got another color
use that I'm going to draw the diagonals
across here like so like so half-face
can't I yeah exactly it's just that this
this base here is this long like made up
of two bits side I'll see ya ya ya cool
doesn't just that's all I had yes you're
right ok now we've got our kaity up you
gotta cut and we've drawn in these
dangled and we remember back from way
back when we introduced the kite but
these two are perpendicular to each
other ok by the way can I just mention
while you my drawing of diagrams not
only should use a ruler please his
pencil because if you're like me you
know I make mistakes all the time
luckily i'm standing at a whiteboard
where i can just use my finger ok but
you shouldn't just do that on your piece
of paper I'm use pencil so that you can
rub off in a presentiment now since I've
got a right angle here ok what I can do
is just like I consider this car like a
comp is a shame i'm going to think of my
kite as a corpus of shape
yes okay sure I've got a couple of ways
that I can do this i'm going to show you
to wait ok here's the first way I'm
going to do it can you see can you see
if I've got this triangle over here can
you see that these two triangles are
really the same size can you see that
that makes sense like the thing that
makes a kite a kite is that those two
sides are the same and these two sides
are the same so what i can do is i can
move this triangle over to this side I
can move it around sort of twisted round
and it's going to go out with Jordan up
here it's going to go whoops i miss I'll
pick up you see that let me needing that
up a little bit can you see it's rotate
around and yes it's exactly like it's
made a rectangle ok now I can do it not
just with this triangle over here yaar I
can do with the bottom one car tire I'm
gonna take this sand rail and I'm going
to twist it around it's gonna end up on
this side ok man now what I've got is I
combine these two triangles to make a
rectangle and I've combined these two
triangles to make up another rectangle
the two rectangles now ok now i'm almost
there almost finished ok tell me like
these diagonals who's they ok i'm going
to call this long one here i'm going to
call it X right and this shorter one i'm
going to call it why now before i put
wine in there yeah why well why not okay
can you see right this diagonal has been
cut in half we have a special name for
this stuff to the beach does anyone
remember as it bisected very good this
diagonal or Kashia has been bisected
both of the pan but one always has so if
this is whole thing is why and I've
chopped it in half what's each part on
its own it'll be what I've slice it down
the middle so I'm going to get halfway
and half way and they want to put
together I get why so about half way
here and I've got half why here okay
with that all right excellent now let's
have a look at this new rectangle that
we have made this guy okay we know what
the area of a rectangle is right there
okay so therefore it's going to be
length x breath right the area of this
thing is going to be half X Y that's it
that's all there is to now we can do the
same thing for rhombus but just because
we can and I can show you there's lots
of different ways to looking at these
shapes let's not draw a rhombus beside
this rhombuses are called on the alcohol
diamonds in our memories for hosing
often because that's what I things like
doesn't it um here's my rhombus and he's
my kite now I'm going to do it slightly
differently I could do the same trick I
could do the same tree let's do those
diagnose diagonals but just to
illustrate just like with our composite
shapes there's often more than one way
to approach these shapes right so let me
show you another one can you see that
around al rhombus round our diamond
right I could draw one big rectangle
like this
say that again no it's not always now
here's that he's though is the reason
why there's a great question why can I
draw a rectangle around this and a car
always draw a rectangle and the reason
why is because of these right angles in
here okay what I'm going to make is this
triangle and this triangle let me just
number them for you I'll call this one a
one and A two can you see they're the
same triangle make you see they're the
same track I've just flipped it over so
if I have a right angle in here I have a
right angle out there right that's why
and I can do the same thing over here
let's call these affiliate bananas in
pajamas today there's be want to be too
okay they're also the same I keep on
going right here's c1 and c2 d1 and d2
they're all the same okay so that right
angle in the middle this is a right
angle at the corner I'm almost ready
here just like before I'm going to call
my a day that diagonals x and y X goes
all the way from the top to the bottom
and y goes all the way from left to
right okay you might even like to put
some arrows indicate that if you like
necessary but it might be helping okay
now tell me look at this big blue
rectangle what's the area of that big
blue red tape yeah yeah that's exactly
right it's x times y it's the length
times the bread but I don't actually
want the whole rectangle do I I only let
the rhombus on the inside but yeah it's
exactly right the rhombus right because
this part this part the same this part
in this photo it's it's exactly half the
size you see that every bit of the
rhombus has its extra bit from the
rectangle so it's literally half